one sign that things might be about to
get very dicey with Tuesday's election
is that my pillow CEO and founder Mike
Lindell known as Mike pillow or simply
pillow over 54 countries have now been
taken by the machines yeah
he is claiming that he has a real-time
crime desk to monitor deviations and
anomalies of Democrats no doubt
attempting to steal Tuesday's election
listen to what this guy is saying it is
as scary as it is delusional where will
you be election night
I will be at the antenna
and Tanner Frank's speed
um I will be there I'm going to have my
we have two Studios and I'm gonna have
the real crime the real time crime
deaths with cyber guys so you can tune
in to Lindell TV and watch and we're
gonna you want to see what's happening
with your candidate or whatever if it's
getting sold in real time if it is
getting stoled in real time
pillows cyber guys will tell you folks
we are screwed
do it and when they do it we're gonna on
the morning of the ninth yep um if ones
are counting ones that aren't counted
everything's gonna stand out and if they
don't
um here's what we can pray for we can
pray for that the media covers the the
deviations and anomalies and I'm talking
to Fox News Newsmax and the conservative
media they better start reporting
election crime period wow that is a sick
individual or someone who has drank
gallons of his own Kool-Aid I genuinely
don't know you know people write to me
all the time they say Sir tears they're
crying they say is Mike pillow for real
you've interviewed him David is Mike
pillow for real when he says this stuff
we're doing a class action
all machines yes I do not know the
answer
I genuinely don't know the answer I go
back and forth I've now interviewed him
in longer form interviews multiple times
I do not know whether pillow is
delusional
whether he is knowingly saying things
that aren't true to rile people up
I do not have the answer at this point
in time your guess is as good as mine I
would say at this point so we should be
it I don't I continue to think he might
be admitting to crimes claiming he has
cameras on the polling places I don't
know if any of the stuff he's claiming
is legal or if it's actually happening
but we should pay very close attention I
hope you will be with me live on Tuesday
night
that's my sincere hope I will be live
with election results nationally
we'll be going all night till like 8pm
no I'm kidding we're gonna go we're
gonna go until we have definition quite
frankly
um YouTube tuition Facebook I hope
you'll be with me and remember subscribe
on YouTube folks we're pushing to two
million YouTube subscribers I would love
for you to hit that subscribe button
particularly if you're watching and
don't subscribe there's almost 3 million
of you 3 million uh we'll take a quick
break and be right back
we talk about it all the time one of the
biggest contributors to climate change
is deforestation did you know that 15 of
deforestation is due to toilet paper
production alone according to the nrdc
that's why I love our sponsor real paper
real paper makes a sustainable toilet
paper no trees it uses 100 bamboo a
bamboo stock can keep being harvested
indefinitely no deforestation real paper
is certified by the forest Stewardship
Council for responsible harvesting of
the bamboo grass used for their paper
another contributor to climate change
the plastic that the toilet paper comes
wrapped in that's why real paper
involves no plastic packaging and best
of all real paper looks and feels just
like normal traditional toilet paper the
cost is similar it is fantastic on their
website you can do a one-time purchase
or set up an easy recurring subscription
the way that I did my audience gets 30
off your first order plus free shipping
go to realpaper.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman at checkout the link is down
below